SPEAKER 1: The
implications of God
are in the hierarchy of
things, including us,
and in the imperfection, even of
the highest things that we see.
Why would a place
devoted to learning,
to the exercise of the mind,
to rational understanding also
be interested in faith?
Aren't they contradictory?
And that I will address
at a little bit of length
because that would be why
we study Genesis here.
Philosophy is the
love of wisdom.
And wisdom is an achievement
of the intellect,
of what you can know by
thinking things through.
We kind of start with
the things in front of us
and try to understand how
we know what they are.
Same thing when one of
the things in front of us
is each other, ourselves.
What are we?
And so you start with questions.
Socratic philosophy begins
this way with, what are we,
how should we live, what are
these other things we see,
and how do we know
what they are?
How do we figure it out?
And there's a great account of
that in classical philosophy.
And classical
philosophy, of course,
was born in a time before
the Christian faith,
in pagan times, 400 or
so years before Christ.
And their account
runs like this.
They say, well, when
you start thinking
about how you recognize things,
you're asking the question,
how do you use common nouns?
Down there, there's a
glass which they put here
for me in case I get raspy.
And I'll hold it up so
you can see it, all right?
And if you think about
it, that's one glass.
It's a kind.
There are many kinds--
many, many kinds.
And somehow, we
always recognize them.
And the fact that we can
use the common noun "glass"
is the central operation,
according to the classics,
of human reason.
It's the thing we can do that
the other creatures can't do.
And yet, when we realized
that about ourselves
and look inside
ourselves, we see
that whatever it is about
us that makes us different,
that thing, too, is imperfect.
First of all, it's located
in a perishable body.
And second of all,
we have this thing
that is about us, about the way
we learn and the way we think--
that's the reason why
students get dark circles
under their eyes at finals time.
We go from one thing to the
next thing, to the next thing.
And we have to piece them
together while we go.
We don't know
everything at once.
We can't really see anything
except what we can see.
Aristotle says, "There's
nothing in the soul that doesn't
get there through the senses."
So that's a kind of a limit.
Well, once you see what
those problems are,
you can imagine a being that
knows everything in an instant,
sees everything in an instant.
The implications of God are
in the hierarchy of things,
including us, and in
the imperfection, even
of the highest
things that we see.
And that means
that the humanities
raise the question of God.
And so you need to be
thinking about that.
But then, think about this.
How are you going
to know about God?
Because if you imagine a perfect
being, it would be omnipotent.
That means it could do anything.
And then, on the other
hand, to be omnipotent,
it would need to be omniscient.
It would need to
know everything.
And if it was the
origin of things,
it would be the creator.
Now, I will tell you
that in Greek philosophy,
they don't imagine a
creator because they
stick with what they see.
And they see that the
planets are always there.
And they always move in
the patterns they move.
And grown up dogs give
rise to baby dogs.
And acorns produce oak trees.
And so the implication is
that it's gone on forever.
But on the other hand,
they did ask the question,
did all this start somewhere?
And, if so, where?
And if there actually
was a creator, then
he would actually have
to be outside nature.
He wouldn't be just
that dense lump
at the beginning of things.
He'd have to be something
outside that thing
to be the source of it.
And he would need to be an
eternal thing, a thing that
didn't start--
in order to be
perfect, I'm saying.
And so then you start
drawing a picture of God.
And that picture is
supported by the traditions
of learning that come to us,
especially through Judaism
and Christianity.
In Christianity,
"Jesus" is the word.
It's what God has to
say, just like we say.
Use words.
And only we use them.
And so there's an
invitation in the faith
to think and try to explain,
understanding that we're
unlikely to be able to explain
everything at once, including,
especially, the
thing of which we
can have no sensory evidence,
the creator of everything.
And that's why,
in the tradition,
the study of God,
theology, has always
been part of the canon
of the liberal arts
and fits in the
canon, understanding
that the faithful part of
it, the revealed part of it,
that that part is a different
kind of knowing than the kind
that we undertake when
we observe and think
and record and calculate
and, in the natural sciences,
experiment.
And it doesn't mean that
they're not both valuable,
but they are different.
And so to call yourself a
wholly thoughtful people,
as far as a human
being could be--
person-- wholly
thoughtful person,
you'd have to do some
thinking about God.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.